so if you haven't seen the video i
suggest you watch it we can't play it
right now for obvious reasons white
house has no answers on when biden has
ever not not not in the last 12 months
not in the last 10 years ever in his
lifetime
visited the border or how many migrants
have been released into u.s so go to the
bottom to exchange to read the uh
exchange so so fox news correspondent
peter ducey press white house press
secretary as pressed white house press
secretary gen zaki on whether biden has
ever in his life been to the southern
border saying i've been looking all
morning and we cannot find any records
of him at visiting the border as
president vice president senator or even
as a concerned citizen why would that be
okay so this is not about as a president
or vp period ever go a little lower she
pushes a little bit more saki could not
provide a date and says she would check
ducey pushed further noting that the
president has made a point in the past
to travel around the country when areas
are affected by wildfires hurricanes to
see the needs of the local community
and then she says well first of all
peter i think the situation at the
border is the result of a broken system
and the president certainly relies on
his experience so whether it was the
work he did to address the root causes
as vice president his efforts when he
was a senate
to support comprehensive immigration
reforms that at a time was or being or
done being done
and worked towards a bipartisan way
something that certainly we think should
be the case today he uses all his
experience from the passage anyways the
whole point is she could not say that
he's ever been to the southern border so
this is my question for you that's my
question for you
does that matter and if yes why does
that matter yeah he needs to see what's
going on on the border he needs to have
an experienced it so he can base his
leadership and his decisions on
something he's seen for himself and and
it's also for the people there and to be
a leader you need to you know
i always tell my kids leave from the
front you know this is a guy who's never
even been to the place down you know a
three-hour flight from him
yeah the um listen i don't know if
anything outside of optics would occur
from a president being down there but it
does make it seem like okay at least
he's prioritizing this
you know the rhetoric that we've get
from the white house out of this stuff i
mean you know it's amazing how
you know uh law abiding americans they
got no problem yelling at us and telling
us our patience was wearing thin you
know with people that just want to be
left alone meanwhile you got people
you know story you have an actual
humanitarian crisis at your border that
you guys have created just because let's
be honest you need the votes you're
trying to shove as many blue votes into
red states as you possibly can if there
were a bunch of canadians trying to
escape trudeau's socialist paradise up
north coming through the northern border
and turning michigan red watch how fast
there would be an ice wall up up on our
northern border right but listen and
also to that point if i'm correct i
think as many as 25 of all votes in the
recount were from people born outside of
the united states of america in
california so the strategy is working
all right and even beto o'rourke says
he's going to run for governor so he
they've counted enough people coming
across the border where bateau thinks
the third time's a charm who knows he's
going to get in there who knows how many
cartel people are coming across they
don't care i mean you see in the afghans
some of the afghan refugees are raping
people kids here they care about power
and
i verified the story with the gentleman
yesterday and i said is child marriage
taking place right now says absolutely
yeah it's hard he said mothers
are being threatened for their lives
because they have no food they have
nothing they're exchanging their
ten-year-old daughters to other taliban
men in exchange for food and freedom we
did that that is us that's what's gotta
be so
unbelievably
mind-boggling to even think about a
person being put in a situation like
that to make that decision our tax
dollars finance that situation 300
million
you know we just spent a bunch of money
and wasted it to do nothing you know it
wasn't like the taliban was nice before
since i've been on this podcast man you
know a lot of people dm me and and
some of it's awesome and i love the guys
at dma a lot of it's not so awesome but
one of the things i've noticed about my
the more liberal among us are the more
left among us they they disagree with me
very very publicly in the comments but
if they agree with me it's very very
quietly in the dms right but one of the
things they always talk about is look
like taxes are the price we pay for a
civilized society taxes we need to do
this the rich just got to pay a little
bit more and everybody and my whole
thing comes back to guys
we we don't have a revenue problem in
this country there's 4 trillion just in
federal income tax that doesn't take
into account state income tax that
doesn't take into account any of the
soft taxes that you can't pay it doesn't
take into account tickets it doesn't
take into account tolls we do not have a
revenue problem in this country four
trillion dollars we're still running 128
deficit against gdp you think they're
gonna run the country better on seven
trillion than they did on four no way
man so
one of the things that they have to do
now if you're listening to this and if
you're on the left side of the aisle and
we're missing soy man today but you need
to now prove to the rest of us that if
you get more money because the
government's asking to double its budget
right now and they're asking not just
for the money that we're making right
now they're going after future earnings
all right and they're going after our
past with inflation they're going after
our future with investment income and
they're going after our past they're
going to take it all you have to show us
that this money buys something other
than death and destruction
this is what it buys
you need to show us that it doesn't that
the money is going to something other
than lobby firms man you have to show us
that it's going to something other than
defense contractors
21 trillion dollars
two two trillion dollars well no no i'm
saying
if in afghanistan was it 21 trillion
total two trillions so two trillion
dollars 300 million dollars a day for uh
it's two to three trillion dollars two
to three trillion dollars and
well that i think that might have been
one of those out of three trillion
dollars i don't want to give this stat
incorrectly somebody got to look it up
but i think it was out of three trillion
dollars
2.8 trillion went to defense contractors
yeah i don't know that i don't know that
figure right there to verify but uh
going back to the question about biden
never been to the southern border when
lester holter pushed kamala in june
about the fact that you've never been to
the border
and she says what's the big deal i've
never been to italy i've never been to
europe what does that have to do with
anything that was her
laugh after after her life yeah so so so
the question then becomes uh you know in
a in a situation like this okay do you
think obama would have been at the
border right now if he was president do
you think obama would have visited he
understands optics better i actually
think obama would have visited do you
think you think bill clinton would have
visited it yeah do you think hillary
would have visited yeah we know trump
would have visited it yeah do you think
bush would have visited we know what
bush did with 911 he went right there
yeah this isn't by the way this is not a
republican or democratic thing why the
hell are you not visiting this is not a
republican or democratic thing you just
made an actually really great point
about kamala harris like that is also
another reason against this kind of
global government globalization like out
of sight out of mind if this wasn't a
federal problem if it wasn't the federal
border yeah the texans would take care
of the border the texans that live at
that area would handle the border fine
locally they would take care of it yeah
the fact that it's a federalization
somebody that works in dc
and grew up and lives in in san
francisco doesn't give a damn about the
border she did she just like what you
said i've never been in italy either
it's abstract terror so now if we go
global guys do you think somebody in
beijing or somebody some bureaucrat in
germany is gonna give a damn about
southern border you think they're going
to care about you know maricopa county
and arizona man they're not going to
care the bigger government gets the more
global it gets the worst things we'll
get in a micro sense it could be it
could be that biden doesn't have the
energy for a trip like that
or it could be that he's not actually
making anything i don't i don't know
about that let me tell you why i don't
know about that because he went to
delaware for vacation uh just a couple
weeks ago so i think the travel part he
could do i'm actually trying to really
see
why not because does it force the media
on the left to talk about what they're
not doing right let me let me give you
an idea of where i'm going with this i
watched a jake tapper interview the
other day with blinken have you seen
that interview or no it's a 14-minute
question clips okay if you haven't seen
it highly recommend you go watch it jake
tapper like on rogan i said i think jake
tapper's one of the most necessary
people also in america today because
jake uh is a guy that'll still push jake
will ask the question i think jake is
actually
relatively you know if everybody's if
don lemon is far left and you got chris
cuomo here and all these guys center c i
think jake is here which i appreciate
jake doing his job and pushing back he
pushed blinking on a lot of issues he
says look you're still not answering my
question for you what happened there why
did you guys make the decision the way
you guys made
the question i'm asking you is
even the left is right now getting sick
of their candidate that one the left is
sick of it this is not about a left or
right thing right now the left is sick
of it so to go to the thought of saying
well maybe they're not going they're not
going because zucker had a call in the
background not zuckerberg i'm talking no
jeff sucker had a call in cnn saying hey
let's get everybody on the same page and
they do a conference call saying do not
go to the southern border because it's a
bad look because you're going to get so
much hate i don't think that's the case
so why have they not gone there i know
kamala went to el paso i understand that
the whole guatemala el paso all of that
stuff why has he not gone there well you
know it's the same thing
it's a very interesting question i don't
know i i i tend to think you might be
right maybe you know he doesn't have the
capacity to do it how do they know maybe
they know you could i also don't think
he's i really don't think he's a
decision maker guys i really don't think
he is he's going to get you mentioned
he's going to get definitely walking
there he's going to get a lot of
joe biden's he's going to get people
sorry
going back to your point though about
the left media there's two things that
you said were very very interesting and
worth tracking one hunter biden's emails
were confirmed they were confirmed and
that hasn't been covered it was a blip
hasn't been covered at all
the hunter by the nemo's that he was
selling access and that by and that joe
biden was signing off on it was
confirmed it should be a bigger
conspiracy than almost anything in our
lifetime and no one's even talking about
it that's number one they are talking
about it you saw this week what happened
with the honor brighton laptop yeah have
you seen the progress they're making
with it yeah but it wasn't like front
page and it wasn't like all over not yet
but they're but they're about to yeah
yeah they're about to they're not gonna
have a choice and number two on that is
you mentioned don lemon very very very
interesting in the pass off from lemon
show to uh you know there there's a
thing now um with the far left
progressive the racial progressive
specifically while you're saying hold
that thought folks if you're listening
to this i'm actually curious why do you
think they haven't visited biden hasn't
visited the southern border i'm looking
at some of people's comments go ahead
you were saying yeah so the girl who who
went missing and uh you know it's highly
suspected that her boyfriend has
something to do with it um
you know there's there's a racial
component to it apparently that that um
the social justice left hates the amount
of attention that this story is getting
and they're saying if it was a black
woman essentially they're saying this
would have never happened and i guess
the police questioned the boyfriend and
he is not saying anything and don lemon
said that that's white privilege they
would press a they would they would
press um a black kid until they they
said something and chris cuomo my my
mind almost exploded chris cuomo says
absolutely not that you're right not to
speak and then he actually pushed back
against it and i was like whoa did chris
cuomo just disagree with him chris cuomo
said it doesn't matter if you're white
or black they'll do it he says yes but
poor and then down corrected himself
went from black is it poor poor white
and black people he says do you think if
i wasn't down limit if i was a he says
but poor so he changed his position i
saw chris pushing him back i think you
shared that with me yeah very
interesting i was like
if the left is starting to push back
against the left that is good progress
because we got it like you said
i you know the center is where it is
right we talk about the the you know i'm
a prescriber of the horseshoe theory we
talk about a little bit like we think
about left and right in this country
like the furthest thing away from a nazi
is to be a communist so therefore
comey's good that's the whole antifa
thing it's not a linear you know
political spectrum it's a horseshoe
right so the the nazis and and the and
the commies the far right and the far
left are way closer to each other than
they are to anything in the center right
so i mean that's that's kind of the idea
i wish that that was taught
better in school i wish that people had
a better understanding of that but you
know
if the center left can start taking
control of their room if the center left
can can start having a louder voice the
country is headed in the right door it
says because they're cowards all the
stuff they're saying because biden is
because he knows it's going to be all
over the news i actually don't think
that's the case i'd like to know what
uh the reason is and and i don't think
the left or the right knows what the
reason is why they're not going there i
don't know maybe it's something bigger
than we even know
uh but even yesterday when they turn on
the haitians you know that they're
coming here and then you saw uh maxine
waters came out and said yeah you know
haitian lives are black lives if asian
lives matter black lives matter haitian
lives matter and they're coming here
because their country is not good and
they're leaving to come to america we
have to take care of them they're not
coming here to stay and then statistics
came back and said wait a minute these
guys have been living down there for
years so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]